I very vividly remember sitting on a
Hilltop in Maryville watching a tank
battle the proof that as a genocide I
saw it with my own eyes and busha and
European as a conflict reporter I have
to say I've never experienced so much
anxiety as I have in this war they don't
believe that Ukraine both as a country
and as a nation has the right to exist
evidence is clear that what Russia is
doing is a genocide you know ukrainians
chose democracy for themselves you know
the most important place in the world
right now
foreign
I arrived in Ukraine I am almost
embarrassed to say I knew very little
about the country all I knew was you
know post-soviet World blah blah blah
but when I arrived here
I
felt very privileged to witness what I
felt was sort of the the birth of a
democratic culture in Ukraine a
democratic culture isn't just about
government and laws it's about the
spirit of the people and when I first
came here in 2014 and I saw the
volunteer battalions men and women of
all ages who decided to go out there and
fight for their freedom it was
incredibly inspiring for me particularly
I'm I'm in a military veteran from the
United States
and the closest analogy I can come up
with with what I experienced 2014 would
be the days immediately after September
11 2001 in the United States where
Society American society really banded
together and just there's something very
similar happened in Ukraine well when I
first came to Ukraine in 2014 I thought
I would be here for two or three weeks
but that summer I was actually in
mariopal as the Russian forces were
advancing
and I very vividly remember sitting on a
Hilltop in Maryville watching a tank
battle and I thought to myself like this
is crazy a tank battle in Europe in 2014
and I just felt like that story wasn't
being transmitted to the world like
people just weren't taking it seriously
enough
and as I stayed here in Ukraine over the
years I would repeatedly go out to the
front lines and experience trench
warfare with artillery and Rockets
and it just seemed absurd or crazy to me
that a land war was going on in Europe
and it felt sort of like a secret for
all these years and I thought that it
was important to stay here and remind
Europe the United States and the world
that there's a land war going on in
Europe and I always worried that this
war could blow up into something far
worse
and that's what happened this year but I
think you know clearly
um my initial impressions of ukrainians
Love of freedom in their will to fight
it it certainly proved true a million
times over it's what I've seen so far in
2022.
[Music]
unfortunately for many Americans over
the past eight years Ukraine was a story
that was very far away
and it was always a challenge as a
journalist to try and make this war
matter
to people's daily lives in the United
States because the United States
obviously we've worried about terrorism
there was the rise of Isis after 2014
China is a threat to our country now as
well
so it was always a challenge to kind of
cut through that noise to explain why
Ukraine was important and the last eight
years it was mainly what this work could
become
and unfortunately we're at the place now
where the war has become a problem that
the United States
and Europe can no longer ignore in the
lead up to Russia's February 24th
Invasion there are so many stories and I
did many stories too about the
territorial Defense Forces and the
civilians who are preparing to fight
and there's always this question it's
like are they for real
the ukrainians really have that much
courage
to grab you know their their
grandfather's Kalashnikov and go out
there and stare down a Russian tank are
they really gonna do it but after those
first three days when everybody expected
Kiev to fall and president zielinski
didn't leave the capital the Ukrainian
people the Ukrainian soldiers stood
their ground and it became less about
sort of the scale and the spectacle of
the war so to speak and it was just an
inspiring story of a people who aren't
going to roll over and be invaded who
are going to stand up for values that my
country the United States stands for
Freedom democracy Liberty for everybody
ukrainians fought for those values and
they've so far won and so I think that
this story really resonated because
ukrainians became the world's hero
foreign
[Music]
I mean all the dead bodies
I mean that's not I was a soldier I was
a pilot I'd been in combat as a
combatant you know I know what the toll
of war is supposed to look like on a
battlefield and it's not hundreds of
dead civilians who were summarily
summarily executed you hear what Russia
is saying about this war which is you
know basically they don't believe that
Ukraine both as a country and as a
nation has the right to exist I mean
that's the most black and white
clear-cut example of a genocide I can
think of
and here we are in Europe again you know
one human lifetime later from the
Holocaust and people are still quibbling
about whether this is a general side or
not I think that's irresponsible I mean
I think we have a duty as journalists to
call out the truth when we see it and to
not let our
you know our desire to be objective
get in the way of our Our obligation to
be truthful about what we're seeing here
and I think that you know the evidence
is clear that what Russia is doing is a
genocide and I think that you know if we
try and equivocate
that fact or if we try to downplay it or
play word games we're essentially
empowering Russia to continue so I think
it's important to call out exactly what
Russia's doing and that is a genocide
[Music]
the conflict journalists you know one of
the hardest things is to be objective
because I've lived in Ukraine for almost
nine years now
it's it's almost impossible to report on
this war and be emotionally objective
about it I think as journalists we need
to not confuse being objective with
being
truthful and if you count Russia's
propaganda their outright pulled lies as
a legitimate like contrary viewpoint
you are distorting the truth and so I
think it takes a little bit of guts from
journalists sometimes to say okay maybe
I will
by the letter of the law be a little bit
less objective because I'm not counting
Russia's Viewpoint as a legitimate
viewpoint
but you're getting closer to the truth
and I feel like the highest law in
journalism is to tell the truth
[Music]
one of the biggest differences between
say what I experienced in Afghanistan
and what I've experienced in Ukraine is
that you know ukrainians chose democracy
for themselves
it wasn't something that was dictated to
them or it wasn't something that they
were told to do ukrainians of their own
accord in 2014 during the revolution of
dignity chose this path for their
country and they fought for it for over
eight years now the closest
parallel I think I've seen to Ukraine in
my reporting would be my time with
Tibetan Freedom Fighters when China
invaded Tibet they tried to erase
tibetan's culture
challenge tibet's right to exist and
everyday Tibetans monks included took up
arms and fought back
and even though Tibet and Ukraine are
very
you know distinct cultures
geographically and in many other ways
that Spirit to fight for your nation's
right to exist against a bully was
something that really struck me and also
just the fact that normal people people
who never wanted to be soldiers people
who never thought they'd pick up a gun
and go to battle decided that they were
going to do this for the sake of their
families for the sake of their country's
future that's just like the most
inspiring story in the world when people
who don't want to fight choose to do so
to stand up for you know the people who
need to be protected and to stand up
against these sort of forces of evil in
the world that are challenging
um
the things that we all we all believe
[Music]
when I served in the in the U.S Air
Force I deployed to Afghanistan and Iraq
and I was involved in counter-insurgency
fights uh you know mainly gun battles
and kicking down doors in the night
things like that but when I first
arrived in Ukraine in 2014 I like I said
I sold tank battles rocket attacks heavy
artillery and then later on trench
warfare and then this year we've seen
you know the full-scale invasion
comprising air attacks and missile
attacks
so it's a completely different type of
War than what I experienced as a
combatant and also what I saw as a
journalist in some of these other
conflicts not only is the scale of
Destruction and in death much higher
right now because of this conventional
State on state War which exists in
Ukraine but also the risk of this war
spilling over Beyond Ukraine's Borders
or escalating to something of truly
catastrophic levels within Ukraine we're
not talking about tens of thousands of
casualties but hundreds of thousands of
casualties people may say that there's
lots of conflicts around the world why
is this one different well it is
different because this is like like you
said a conventional conflict between two
modern militaries and the potential for
this the spiral out of control
potentially now I mean people here in
Kiev are taking seriously the notion
that Russia could use a tactical nuclear
weapon at some point
maybe a few months ago that would have
seemed absurd but with Russia's back
against the wall could happen this
conflict does have the potential to
become
much worse than it is now and I think
that that is one very important
um motivating factor for us to keep our
eyes on it and to to not let this war
become forgotten again
[Music]
I think they
to someone who would make the argument
that by cutting off weapons to Ukraine
this war would end they clearly don't
know ukrainians
because ukrainians were willing to fight
for the last eight and a half years
without high Mars without javelins
without all these new tools that we've
given this country
so if suddenly you know the Western
military aid dried up ukrainians would
fight with sticks and stones that they
had to to not only
stop Russia's advance but to turn it
back and regain their territory the best
thing we can do is to support the sight
of the good in this conflict and to
allow ukrainians to win win this win
this war you know a lesson that I hope
we have learned
from the last 30 years of post-soviet
Russia is that if we give Russia What It
Wants in hopes and with the hope that
they will turn around and have a change
of heart and suddenly become our friends
we're deluding ourselves the only way to
put the Russian threat behind us is to
defeat it
and I think that you know Ukraine is
fighting for its existence right now and
who are we to tell them to to give up
[Music]
speaking about the the motivations of
some of the Foreign Legion soldiers
I can draw upon my own
story as a journalist who came to this
conflict you know I left my career in
the military in a 2012
and I remember distinctly the first
feeling I had was I asked myself like
what's next
and who am I and so when you leave the
military I think you you lose a very
important part of yourself and that's
your sense of purpose in life
the feeling like you're not living to
make money here for status you're living
for an ideal you're living for a higher
purpose and other people count on you
and you have a valuable role in this
world and I truly believe that what we
often call post-traumatic stress after
war is not that soldiers are wounded by
War it's that they come home to lives in
peace that just don't match sort of the
amplitude of living that they
experienced in combat I came to Ukraine
because I was searching for that sense
of meaning in life and I wanted you know
to continue that that sense of
an idea that my life had purpose it was
important I found that as a conflict
journalist coming to Ukraine and helping
to tell Ukraine's story I imagine that
many Foreign Legion soldiers came here
looking for purpose and very similar to
my experience
after they arrived here they fell in
love with the Ukrainian people the
culture and were inspired by seeing this
country fight for its existence and its
freedom America during the generation at
which we were at war in Iraq and
Afghanistan when I would come home from
those Wars I always felt very
disconnected from my homeland because
people
didn't understand the realities of war
and they kind of took their freedom for
granted in a lot of ways but when you
come to Ukraine the war is here and you
see people so committed and so
passionate about fighting for the things
that so many Americans take for granted
right peace freedom and democracy and
prosperity and all these things like
that's what ukrainians want and that's
what they're fighting for and it's so it
I think that as somebody who's been to
War as a combatant you come to Ukraine
and it immediately Feels Like Home you
immediately feel like everybody here is
a a veteran that you can sort of you
know immediately come to terms with
understand when you talk to them and
that's something that's unfortunately
kind of rare for many veterans when they
return back to society whether it be in
the United States or you know another
European country
[Music]
I think you know one advantage that
Ukrainian veterans will have after this
full-scale war is over compared with
earlier before February 24th when it was
um you know trench warfare confined to
the Dome boss is that the war now
affects
almost all of Ukrainian Society so
Ukrainian veterans returning now will
have an experience very different than
veterans prior to February 24th and very
different than American veterans coming
home from Iraq and Afghanistan coming
back to Country a country that was very
much you know
quarantined so to speak from the Direct
effects of combat so I feel like
Ukrainian veterans after this full-scale
war is over
won't feel so isolated because there
will be a lot more
sort of societal understanding so it's
going to be very important to give
Ukrainian veterans a role in society
perhaps like the United States to
encourage them to have some sort of GI
Bill program in Ukraine to encourage
them to go pursue a University degree or
a master's degree to to find a new path
in life to recreate sort of that sense
of identity that they may lose
coming back from war because the hardest
part of coming back from war is often
not the memories of the terrible things
you've experienced is losing your
friends it's losing that camaraderie
that sense of tribe that you experienced
in the front lines and so whatever
method that Ukrainian Society can come
up with I think the most important thing
is to not let these veterans feel alone
it's important to get these veterans
out of their Apartments together have
veterans groups where they can interact
with each other experience you know
human relations in real life but most
importantly to just not let them be
alone when they come back
[Music]
social media in this war has definitely
been a double-edged sword without a
doubt I think you know on the one hand
we are able to document
war crimes to show the effects of like
you know missile strike and the Wong
criminal joke or the mass Graves and
bucha and izume we're able to show that
in real time
what's distressing however is even
though there's so much more proof
of these war crimes being transmitted on
social media there is an equal and
opposite reaction of mistruth being
pumped out so sort of cloud the truth
within this sort of nebula of of Lies
among people who aspire to understand
the truth or who have the the notion
that Ukraine is on the right side of
this conflict I think that the social
media coverage
you know is a source of Truth for them
it's a source of information
but for those who support Russia
um you know they just they don't they
don't buy it even if you show them a
picture of something or a live video
from from a mass grave they still won't
believe it so in some ways you know
social media is unable to cut through
people's pre-existing biases which is
pretty scary as a conflict reporter I
have to say I've never experienced so
much anxiety as I have in this war
because every time I go on social media
and Report something I've seen or have a
picture of something I've experienced an
explosion or attack
you really have to think are you helping
the other side are you helping
Russia to you know Target its missiles
and am I doing something that's going to
get somebody killed by posting
information or a video you really have
to think about whether something a piece
of information which might be good for
your career which maybe you get out
ahead of the pack and break some news is
that worth potentially risking people's
lives I mean there's good and bad to
social media in this war
um but you know Kudos hats off to
Ukraine for having a very strong social
media presence and making its case you
know like I think there is a lot of
like Russia's information Warfare
capabilities are really
you know vaunted before the war that
people talked it up a lot right Russia
is the master at information Warfare but
I think we've it's pretty clear at this
point that that Ukraine has far
surpassed Russia and the ability to use
social media uh
to present its side of the conflict and
to use social media to to its benefit
good morning
it's unprecedented that you we have so
much visibility what's going on on the
Russian side because the telegram
channels of Russian soldiers you can see
what's happening with them
and then also you know just the war sort
of in general the rest of the world you
can go on Twitter and
almost in real time watch combat I mean
I remember yesterday there was videos of
Russian soldiers surrendering uh near
curacon it was just extraordinary to
watch that within hours of it actually
happening and um I don't think I think
we've sort of entered a new
New Era as far as information
how information is used in Warfare but
it is
yeah it is distressing however that
you know many people still are unable to
accept the truth people still question
whether or not Russian soldiers
committed the atrocities and Butcher and
European it's just amazing that even
with so much incontrovertible evidence
out there
if you have a bias if you have a you
know a slant in your mind already
you people are willing to overlook
the truth to confirm what they believe
and that's scary
[Music]
the number one message I would send to
any foreign journalists come in Ukraine
is that this story is not seven months
old
it's eight and a half years old
and eight and a half years ago Ukraine's
Army was
basically nothing and the people had
just gone through the revolution of
dignity and it was
you know after that in 2014 that this
Spirit of resistance and resilience was
born in Ukraine it didn't begin on
February 24th 2022 it began
February 2014 after the maid on
so I think it's important for
journalists to understand sort of the
context of the last
eight years and why ukrainians have been
so courageous why have they fought so
fiercely because this war has been going
on for almost a decade and this was what
we've seen in this full-scale Warfare
over the last seven and a half months
has sort of been the the culmination of
a nearly decade long story if there's
one piece of advice to a journalist
that's here is
um
to combat the mythroughs being
spread about this war you need to go out
there and be present
at this Overlook looking across the
April River in central Kiev you can hear
the sounds of battles in the distance
and meanwhile you have families with
small children walking by people walking
their dogs
go out for an evening run and it just
underscores the absolute surreal nature
of Life achieved these days as you have
these signs of normal life slowly
starting to return
made the you know the presence of War
being here is a great first step because
you're not sitting in a newsroom in DC
or New York and you are Googling your
stories
but you need to be here and you need to
you know you don't have to go run
through the trenches and put your life
on the line but talk to people go see
things with your own eyes have your
boots on the ground perspective that's
the best way to cut through the noise
and to tell the truth
[Music]
I lived in Paris for a few years when I
was younger
and I love living there because that's
where history happened when I moved to
Ukraine I had this overwhelming sense
that I'm where history is happening this
is it this is you know the most
important place in the world right now
this is the epicenter of Our Moment in
history our collective experience in
this life like we're living through
something that people will remember for
hundreds maybe even thousands of years
this is incredibly important historic
moment to be here and to experience this
it's incredibly gratifying because you
feel like you are have a front row seat
to
probably the most important story of our
lifetimes and even the last eight years
just to see how the incar the entire
country has changed so much I remember
spending a lot of time in mariopal over
the last eight and a half years when I
first got there in 2014 very Bleak kind
of post-soviet place
but the youth the young people who live
there the millennial generation
transformed that City
into this really bright promising place
[Music]
and I think that's such a tragedy then
that Russia went in and destroyed that
city
um and I think that what happened to
Mary Hoople is emblematic or
representative of what we don't want to
happen to Ukraine
we don't want Russia to ruin this
unbelievable sense of hope
that Ukrainian people particularly the
young people have for their future and
you see the manifestation of that hope
and how hard they're willing to work
whether they're volunteers or soldiers
journalists ukrainians are really
willing to put it all on the line to
achieve this vision of their future
whatever Russia is trying to do to
extinguish that has been unsuccessful so
far ukrainians have inspired the world
you really have and I think that when
this War began
people may have doubted
you know your ability to resist or your
will to resist many people now will
believe that they will believe that
democracy is worth fighting for
because we've seen how hard ukrainians
are fighting for it I think what's
Happening Here is not just going to this
story will not just stay within Ukraine
it will have
you know after a shocks have effects
across the world in a good way
and so yeah I think
we have a lot to thank Ukraine for
Slava Ukraine